let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
well happy happy hump day happy hump day
you know what that time it is
time for let's talk to Tony Michaels
podcast every Wednesday
three o'clock Central four o'clock
Eastern right here on YouTube Twitter
and twitch
we have a lot to get to today
we've got uh swollen balls we gotta deal
with uh Larry Nasser
the Chicago the California recall
Chicago the California recall and then
we also we also want to get to mark
milley and treason
oh geez
so these are the topics that we want to
talk about today but first off I want to
start with uh Nicki Minaj and swollen
balls and misinformation
about vaccines and how it can affect
your junk or how it doesn't affect your
junk
what in the actual [__] are we still
doing
with this vaccine swollen balls makes
you impotent Nicki Minaj tweets out
something about uh a cousin she has
knows a friend who has a dog who knows
another dog down the street whose owner
knows a guy who has a cousin who read on
Facebook from his uncle
that some guy had swollen balls because
of the vaccine
the world erupts uh the in Trinidad they
waste a whole two days worth of
government's time to try to track down
who's got swollen nuts and who doesn't
and rather the vaccine
swells your testicles or Not Jesus
[__] Christ
and in this country in this country
we've had
Trump humping
Evangelical paste eaters running out to
the feed store because the Facebook feed
store pharmacist has told them all the
cures for covid is on the feed store
shelves down at Tractor Supply
come on people
they run out of the horse dewormer so
now now they're drinking antiseptic
apparently so poison control is
overwhelmed by antiseptic
calls
this is all because of misinformation
and really and this is not surprising
I've talked about uh social media
algorithms
on the show before and everyone wants to
blame the algorithm everyone wants to
blame Facebook in particular for
misinformation and really honestly it's
garbage in garbage out
should we be surprised that there's a
certain percentage of this country that
is looking for any reason any reason
whatsoever
to own the libtards
are to secure their freedom
whatever the [__] it is they're trying
to do
and obviously obviously there's a market
for stupidity
because these people are seeking out
this information and algorithms on
social media
are garbage in garbage out
garbage in
garbage out and it's a it's a a trash
Heap
a trash Heap on Facebook here in this
country
convincing people to poison themselves
to cure them of covet
and a lot of these people are ending up
in the hospital
regretting their decision to gobble Down
horse paced as the as the Facebook
pharmacist would prescribe to them
only they end up in the hospital
suffering and dying from a deadly
pathogen a respiratory disease that
everyone's been saying hey hey if you're
paying attention if you're really paying
attention to the interwebs go somewhere
where the information has uh I don't
know things called facts in it math
the vaccine not only has been
widely widely accepted
as a fantastic prevention but the
numbers in the data prove it out and not
only that millions of people have gotten
this thing so us people who have been
vaccinated listening to you dumb [__]
Yammer on and on and on about is some
product at the feed store that's gonna
cure what ails you
are only laughing at you when you end up
dying in the hospital at this point
because you're not dying from covid
anymore I mean it's coveted that's
killing you but it's stupidity that
you're dying from it's stupidity
because you're not you're not [__]
listening
and this is all part of this right-wing
fascist
Allure that is running rampant around
the entire [__] planet in this
country in particular
we're gonna get to that here a little
later about how California canceled
trumpism
but it's running rampant running rampant
well
it seems as if it's running rampant only
to the people it wants to run rampant
with
vaccinated people
in general are not being hospitalized
and definitely are not dying like the
unvaccinated are
now the president United States decides
to put an OSHA regulation decides to
compel OSHA to have a regulation to keep
workplaces safe and these boneheads
still still aren't listening you're
still not listening it might be my
choice it is your choice make a choice
you want your job or you don't want your
job make your [__] Choice make your
choice and move on we all want to get
back to you know normal type [__] we're
tired of waiting on you [__] to
make a choice so make your choice and
move along every choice has consequences
the consequences of getting vaccinated
and making that choice
is that you have a damn good chance of
not being hospitalized a damn good
chance of not even Contracting the
disease
the virus
and a even better chance of not [__]
dying
that's the consequences I mean you got
that 24-hour period after your first or
second shot that you kind of feel like
[__]
and you know you get your arms a little
stiff for a day or two those are the
consequences
not being hooked to a [__] machine a
death machine
pluck your head out of your [__]
asses even the pope even the pope is
saying hey hey you [__] idiots
we Humanity has had a damn good
relationship with vaccines
for decades and decades and decades and
decades Humanity has a damn good
relationship with vaccines it saved
millions of lives not just from
Coronavirus
measles mumps polio come on people this
is not [__] rocket science
we've been doing this for a long [__]
time
so this misinformation thing
is really continue continue continue
contain we're gonna keep we're gonna
keep with the stupidity because again
the algorithms that are out there on
social media it's garbage in garbage out
just like Nicki Nicki Minaj tweets out
that she knows a guy somewhere that
possibly knows another guy who could his
balls swelled up because he got the
vaccine
and his dick won't work what
and everyone of course she has
gazillions of fans across social media
so the algorithm pumps this in
and it's garbage in garbage out garbage
in garbage out well take out the [__]
trash people it's time we take out the
trash
and just ignore this [__] just scroll on
you don't like it it's stupid scroll on
stop paying attention to the Facebook
feed store pharmacist
okay enough of it
enough of it
so before we get to the um California
recall uh because we definitely want to
talk about that and what the uh
political ramifications are for the
California recall
um yeah we don't even really have to
discuss the results from last night
because it was such a trouncing
Gavin Newsome completely [__]
obliterated what would be uh an election
him versus Larry Elder
because uh Caitlyn Jenner didn't even
hardly appear on the results
but before I get to that I want to talk
because there was a hearing today and I
believe this is very important to talk
about and I actually want to show you a
clip uh at least one of Simone biles
here if we have time of a uh it's a
senate hearing
and it's about that [__] monster
Larry Nasser who abused hundreds and
hundreds God knows how many really
hundreds of of young women
in the USA Gymnastics
and Simone bile Four Women showed up to
give testimony today I want to show this
Simone biles clip
um and and there are several different
reasons uh why and I don't you know I
don't normally show video clips uh on
here other than some other things but I
don't show news Clips normally but today
I want you to see this now because I
want you to see how much of an American
hero Simone biles is because if you
remember
several months ago when the Olympics
were going on people were piling on top
of her because she wouldn't do backflips
for America
you [__]
so I want to show you her clip in
particular to give you some context and
maybe why maybe why she wasn't prepared
to do backflips anymore
and it doesn't make her any less of an
American or American hero or someone to
look up to
what she did today by going in front of
the cameras in the Senate every little
girl should look up to Simone biles
every single one of them should be proud
that she
she is a role model in this country so
any of you out there that are Simone
biles uh uh critics and thinks that only
only only her doing backflips makes her
an American only her doing backflips
makes her patriotic you can go [__] all
the way off [__] him
so it appears that the FBI because uh uh
director Ray testified as well
and of course you know piled on the
condolences like everyone else but the
only thing director Ray it seems that
he's done at this point is to fire the
lead investigator in charge of this case
that had ignored the case of Larry
naster Nasser back in 2015.
so
there's not hundreds and hundreds of
women
are abused by Larry Nassar
and one man one man at the FBI
um he gets punished
and we're still in this cycle and even
[__] Ted Cruz
Cancun Crews at [__] snow lizard
he goes on and on and on on a diatribe
about how you know uh he he feels sorry
for what happened to these women and on
and on and on he went and then he talked
about how there must be a child out
there that is watching this now that is
being abused by a monster and they're
looking to this as comfort well Ted Cruz
you and you support the [__] law that
your state just passed that would allow
that would force force a 13 year old
girl to cover her to carry her brother
to term
because her [__] dad or her uncle or
whoever is a [__] monster
you you [__] piece of [__]
it's enough of this [__] garbage
where we have to put up with this
hypocrisy Ted Cruz does not need to be
questioning women at all he has no
respect for him he has no respect for
the autonomy what the [__] does Ted Cruz
have the right to sit there and question
any woman any woman about the autonomy
of her body when he doesn't believe that
they have the right to it
you [__] piece of [__]
but the FBI is fired the lead
investigator that's a good start
uh I believe there should be a criminal
investigation not just into the lead
investigator but also the the bureau
chief that was his supervisor
because apparently that [__] is
living a great retirement right now he's
retired
he's having fun having vacations he's
doing great he's doing great well isn't
that just [__] swell
so any of these [__] at the
Olympic group or at the FBI
that either covered up or knew something
was going on and didn't act
with their Authority
should be criminally investigated
it should be smoked out and criminally
investigated
and I'm going to show you why here in a
second why it should be because you're
gonna watch one of the greatest
gymnastics gymnast of all [__] time
all time she does [__] that no other
gymnast has ever dreamed of doing
one of the strongest women probably in
our entire [__] country
she had she had the strength and the
courage
to look at her team and say I'm a
liability I am not an asset to the team
and made sure her team had the best
chance to win at the Olympics she had
the courage to do that she wasn't weak
you [__] boneheads
it's white male fragility is out of
[__] control she wasn't weak she was
strong
she knew herself she knew her team she
had confidence in them and she's a
[__] leader unlike any of you
[__] wherever dream of being
Ted Cruz
but I want to show you exactly exactly
how Larry Nassar and not just Larry
Nasser but all his enablers rather it
was at the organization that he worked
at or law enforcement protecting that
[__] piece of garbage
for whatever reason it doesn't matter it
it does not matter the reason why
I want to show you the face
of strength
and what that can do and why women
should have the autonomy of their bodies
and their rights in this country
it's enough of this [__]
it's enough if it's enough
it's out of control so let me show you
this clip
um I've cut this from
MSNBC here so let's go to this clip
I don't want another young gymnast
Olympic Athlete or any individual to
experience the horror that I and
hundreds of others have endured before
during and continuing to this day
in the week
of the layering Oscar abuse
to be clear
take your time
to be clear I blame Larry Nasser and I
also blame
an entire system
that enabled and perpetrated his abuse
USA Gymnastics in the United States
Olympic and paralympic Community
Committee
knew that I was abused by their official
team doctor long before I was ever made
aware of their knowledge
in May of 2015 Rhonda fan the former
head of USA Gymnastics women's program
was told by my friend and teammate
Maggie Nichols that she suspected I too
was a victim I didn't understand the
magnitude of what all was happening
until the Indianapolis Star published
its article in the fall of 2016 entitled
former USA Gymnastics doctor accused of
abuse
so there you have it
there you have it
a woman who could run back flips over
any of these [__] people
one of the strongest
best role models for young women in this
country
and she has a hard time even saying his
[__] name that [__] monster
and not only that not only that
you heard who she who she laid blame to
she heard who she let just Larry Nasser
but anyone who enabled him and they
should smoke out every single nook and
cranny criminally with these people
and Ted Cruz sit down and shut the [__]
up
and tell you until you are are on board
of making sure that women have the
autonomy of their bodies you do not have
the right to speak about a woman
getting her autonomy violated you
[__] piece of [__] there I said it
there I said it
so I want to move on here to uh the
California recall uh last night
yesterday
September 14th
California cancels trumpism
that's right everyone cheer everyone
celebrate now the fight is not over
but this is a very good sign because you
don't even need to see the results to to
be clear what happened and there's so
much to unpack about the politics of
this the visuals of this number one
Gavin Newsom absolutely destroys in the
three to one race uh Larry Elder by all
intents and purposes and the reason why
is because Larry Elder is Trump he's the
embodiment of trumpism Jesus Christ he's
been running around spewing trumpism out
of his [__] out of his pie hole
puking it up for almost 30 years this
guy's been puking up trumpism because he
was trumpism before trumpism was cool
talking about how he doesn't believe in
the America's Disabilities Act he would
have voted no on the Civil Rights Act
[__] [__]
all over minimum wage workers and the
average working class here in the United
States
trumpism before trumpism was cool
and you know what California said [__]
off
get lost we're not we're not having it
here we're not doing it here
the best part is
is they piled on the vote so much that
that Larry Elder had to come out uh last
night
did you guys uh did you guys see this uh
clip or hear this clip where he's giving
his his concession speech which he
didn't have to give a concession speech
he wasn't running in the first place
you're not running against anybody
you were just one of the contingencies
on the ballot you dumb [__]
Elder stands in front of his crowd and
says oh we need to be gracious we need
to be gracious and they Boo Boo don't be
gracious be a dick wad like you've
always been be a dick wad like Trump
blame it on fraud that's that's that's
what they want him to do
and that that's was the whole setup here
I mean that I think the GOP really ran
into a brick wall with this one I
thought oh I think they thought oh well
we'll never really get a the recall on
the ballot and covet happened with all
the restrictions uh they they managed to
get enough signatures to actually uh
trigger a California recall which
just in and of that California really
needs to look at their laws on how easy
it is to recall I mean they recall every
goddamn Governor they got just about
but it triggers a recall for Gavin
Newsom and it looks like Gavin Newsom
may have some trouble until everyone
realizes that
with with the vaccine and this this big
huge wave of the Delta variant running
around the country you see what Texas
and Florida is going through
by doing the opposite of protecting
their citizens like Gavin Newsom is
doing in in California
and everyone realizes well maybe he's
not maybe he's not so goddamn bad maybe
he's actually doing the right things
when it comes to a deadly pathogen
spreading around our communities and
killing people filling up hospitals
maybe he is doing the right thing
he's a [__] leader he's not he's not
placating to the Facebook fans
like Ron DeSantis and Greg Abbott
so California really came out
to vote against trumpism because again I
don't I don't think I don't think that
Joe Biden got 81 million votes I believe
a lot of those votes that Joe Biden got
were against Donald Trump
I think Mickey Mouse could have beat
Donald Trump
there were enough votes against it
I think if Mickey Mouse was the the
governor
of California last night Mickey Mouse
would have kept his his gubernatorial
office
because of the the [__] choice you
had between Mickey Mouse and trumpism
because again Larry Elder it was
trumpism before trumpism was [__]
cool
but politically this is very important
because we have not really had a major
election since 2020 where they're still
claiming fraud and dominion and I don't
know Arizona ballots with bamboo in them
and all kinds of crazy ass [__]
I mean Pennsylvania is even trying to
pass laws Georgia's past laws errors
they're all Texas they're all trying to
bang up the the voting system so that
way they can win because they're
terrified
they're terrified of the numbers that
are piling votes on top of them and it's
in rebuke of them embracing trumpism
that's what it is and really it's
fascism it's I mean you can boil you can
say trumpism but it trumpism is just
[__] fascism with a Maga hat on
come on that's all it is it's [__]
fascism with the [__] Maga hat on
that's it
it runs around wearing a moga head
I mean God damn we see that today with
all these boneheads [__] yelling and
screaming about Mark milley don't even
know don't even know that the military
didn't commit a coup
it was the guy who was elected president
who was trying to remain a dictator who
was committing the coup
you stupid [__] it says right there in
the oath enemies foreign and domestic it
says that like they have to say that out
loud they gotta say it out loud that's
how important that little phrase is when
you're talking about enemies foreign and
domestic
because the domestic terrorism in this
country is coming from one goddamn spot
one spot and it's that fascism with the
[__] Maga head on
that's where it's coming from that's
where it that's where it resides are
crazy in this country used to be spread
out all over the place you know we had
flat earthers we had the the people who
thought JFK is some kind of you know Lee
Harvey Oswald or a hundred different
theories you got the you got the the
chemtrail info War Alex Jones whack jobs
you got that you got the 911 conspiracy
right they were spread out all over the
toast as it were you know the jelly was
really spread out nice and even so we
didn't notice as much crazy
now they're all [__] gathered up in
one goddamn spot
on a group on an Ivermectin group on
Facebook listening to Uncle Ned the
Facebook pharmacist
Jesus [__] Christ
and that's that's our problem is the the
[__] 13 14 of this country that's
lost their goddamn minds are completely
[__] delusional they're all on the
same page they're all on the same
algorithm right now on social media
they're all in one [__] spot
it's all one goddamn convention anymore
with this Q Anon Maga Trump hump and
Evangelical [__]
and they're running around the country
again spreading misinformation
and they can't stop they can't stop
themselves I mean even with this
California race The Narrative is going
to be oh Democrats cheated in dominion
and and voting machines and Court
Supreme Court and I don't know what the
[__] they're in I mean even even [__]
Grandpa Poopypants
[__] to bet on this one
I mean they they were they've been
promising all over this country all over
this country they've been promising
these these these these [__] Maga
trumpers that this this was in the sack
the California recalls in the sack and
Larry Elder
Larry Elder is going to be the governor
I mean they they pretty much that's what
they are promising these people just
like they were promising them that Trump
was going to take over back in March he
was going to be the 19th president or
some dumb [__] and then in April he was
going to take over because the
military's in charge that's the funny
part about Mark milley isn't it isn't it
how they said how all these people who
are now all of a sudden against Mark
milley protecting our democracy
protecting our [__] democracy from a
wannabe Hitler like [__] Donald Trump
so the military steps in it's kind of
funny how back in March and April and
the beginning of the year when when Joe
Biden took the oath to be the president
United States they claimed the military
and Trump was in charge now oh it's bad
that the military's in charge they don't
know what they believe that's why this
is so flimsy that's why it was so easy
for California to slam dunk this
[__]
three to one not even [__] close you
didn't have a [__] prayer not a
[__] prayer
and with all the video and clips of
Larry Elder un uncovered
showing that he was Trump before Trump
was cool
I mean he made Rush Limbaugh look like a
puppy
but California said [__] off
[__] off [__] off you can [__] off
and we gotta next we got a race here
coming up
that Democrats have a chance to tell
Trump isn't to [__] off again and we
need to gear up for it I don't care what
state you're in you need to be yelling
and screaming at the top of your lungs
we have a Virginia Governor's race
that I believes
gonna look like the California race
we're gonna get real results in an
election to show that this country does
not want trumpism we're [__] sick of
it
just because there's a half a dozen
people showing up at [__] town hall
meetings and school board meetings
yelling and screaming [__] that they
read on Facebook into a microphone does
not mean this country wants that type of
[__] [__]
we don't we're sick of the [__] and
it's clear from the results in
California
I mean people were sweating bullets
rather Gavin Newsom would would get 51
percent
well he soared past that
way past that
so on to
the next conspiracy theory because Rand
Paul is already starting to make the
[__] rounds today
this guy is about as much of a military
strategist as he is a [__] doctor
don't you think it's dumb [__]
saying something about how Millie's
committed treason or some [__] how he
Millie was trying to commit a coup no he
was trying to prevent one are you people
listening
are you [__] listening Jesus Christ
the breaking headline is Millie saves
American democracy and Maga all at once
the Trump Pumpers all at once say arrest
him for saving democracy what
what are you people yammering about yeah
maybe maybe maybe maybe he broke his
duty
but he didn't break his oath
maybe he he stepped on chain of command
but if you really read the story if you
really look at what happened that the
state department was involved in this he
wasn't demanding anything he wasn't
giving orders to anybody because the
joint chief of staff is not a commanding
officer they're an advisor to the
executive branch because our military is
controlled by civilians the president of
the United States and the Secretary of
Defense
that's where the command and the orders
for operations come from not not not
from Mark Milly
all's Mark milley was doing is what he
was doing in public he was doing it in
private
and making sure that not just not just
the the
military in general but the commanders
out there and the people that were in
charge if we were to have a strike on
another country understood that they
should bookmark the part of their oath
that says your oath is not
is not to a person it's to the
Constitution and your and the
Constitution and your oath says
you you are
going to stop any enemies foreign and
domestic
domestic being the key word there
you know like in this country or in our
government or in our military because
here's the thing you can't you can't uh
carry out an unlawful order in the
military just because a commander tells
you something doesn't mean you carry
that order out if it's unlawful
and all's Mark Billy was trying to do is
make sure everyone understood what the
procedures were for any kind of military
strike and what the legality was
he did this in public people he did it
in public
and I I found two times but I think it
was three times that Mark milley
actually got in front of a microphone
and was reiterating this not just to the
American public and not just to all the
the the members and service members of
the military but I believe he was trying
to tell the [__] uh the Cheeto dust
mobster Grandpa poopy pit pants himself
that hey when you take your oath your
oath is not to a person
there is no dictator in this country
the commander-in-chief is just a
commander-in-chief of the armed services
he's not a dictator
he's not a fear her
the your oath is to the Constitution the
document
and this came this these calls
came
a couple days after
a [__] coup attempt
Mark milley had proof had proof right in
front of his eyes
that something was afoot that someone
somewhere possibly in the White House
was trying to commit a coup to stay in
power to remain the American dictator I
mean what the [__] what the [__] was
Mark Milly supposed to assume if if
Donald Trump would have been successful
that day
if Donald Trump would have been
successful in overturning the
Constitution the constitutionality of of
Congress actually certifying the vote of
the states which had already been
counted had already been cast had
already been [__] voted on and
certified by the states it was over it
was done but whatever coup attempt he
was trying on January 6 to overturn the
Constitution of the United States what
the [__] did people think was gonna
happen if Trump would have been
successful in wiping his ass with the
Constitution
Mark May we've seen it play in his day
just like all of us
I mean if you're gonna blame Mark milley
or something I guess blame him having
[__] reason logic critical thinking
skills
to be able to determine that that Donald
Trump the current president United
States is trying to become an American
dictator
the leader of yalkaida
it wasn't that hard it wasn't rocket
surgery
so of course Mark Miller acted in the
interest of the Constitution
and not not the military taking over you
stupid bastards
Rand Paul Glenn Beck Fox News oan you
[__] morons
he wasn't acting in the interest of the
military taking over he was acting in
the interest to make sure a dictator
didn't commit a coup so that the next
president who was duly elected by the
people
and the Constitution laid out who is
going to be president which was Joe
Biden so he could remain as an advisor
role to Joe Biden not be hung in the
Square
because the dictator deemed him a
treasonous [__] which of course of
course Grandpa Poopypants has to has to
put out a letter
has to put out a a
screen image tweet
about Al Mark milley oh he committed
treason he committed treason because he
tried to commit a coup no he was trying
to prevent you from committing a coup by
any means necessary because here's the
scariest part about the whole goddamn
thing
is that Mark milley I'm sure did not
pull
the idea that a nuclear war could happen
with China out of his [__] ass I'm
sure that's not what happened
I'm sure he was in earshot I mean Jesus
Christ
the Cheeto dust mobster Grandpa
Poopypants wanted a [__] nuke a
hurricane
I'm sure he was with an earshot of this
dumb [__] when this buffoon was
talking about what what's the ways I
could remain in power if I lose the
election because apparently Mark milley
was on a phone call with his counterpart
in China before the election
and then a couple days after the
insurrection
but Mark milley had been in front of a
microphone and since the beginning of
December to try to tell the American
people hey hey hey
the oath is to the Constitution not a
person he was warning us the whole
goddamn time
January 6 happened
the proof is in the pudding he can see
he can see and attempt to coup
and he decides to protect the American
Constitution which he's sworn an O2 of
enemies foreign and domestic
Donald Trump is the enemy do you not
understand he he was not getting a coup
attempt against him he was on his way
out it was over it was certified it was
done but he's talking about nuclear war
or starting a war
with someone to remain in power maybe I
don't know who who knows you know they
had all these ideas about the
Insurrection act and and martial law
this this is where it really bleeds into
dangerous territory with people like
Sydney Powell and Mike Flynn and Rudy
Giuliani sitting there you know
snowballing with the president late at
night in their pajamas trying to figure
out how the [__] they're going to remain
in power in this country so they don't
get criminally prosecuted
it's pretty [__] simple it's not
difficult to understand it really isn't
it's really not hard to determine that
this motherfucker's a crook and the
people around him either either have
become Crooks or were Crooks
and there's going to be some foreign
punishment for the Crooked [__] they do
and the only way to protect themselves
is to make sure that Grandpa Poopypants
can change his diapers in the White
House and not down at Mar-A-Lago
because that's what was happening is
this guy was losing his [__] mind
losing his [__] mind he'd [__] his
diaper he needed his ass wiped
and Mark Billy wiped it for him
he made sure to protect our country and
our interest the Constitution the
continuation of American democracy here
not the coup attempt on Democracy you
understand that right you get it do you
understand that the one that was trying
to commit a coup was not mark milley
he was acting in the interest of the
American people we the people and the
Constitution
it was the Cheeto dust mobster that was
trying to commit a Cheeto Confederate
coup
kangaroo coup Cheeto dust kangaroo coo I
don't know I got there's all kinds of
[__] names for this goddamn thing
now the political ramifications of this
book from Bob Woodward and Bob Costa The
Bobs the Bob's book coming out at this
point when we're still when we're still
working through the select committee I
believe this is a little early for this
information but it is what it is that's
the freedom the the the the freedom that
we have of a free press here in this
country and sometimes Freedom has
consequences and the consequences of the
freedom of press is sometimes we know
things before we should know them
it's how it happens sometimes I believe
we're gonna find this out through the
select committee I believe all the
information that has been released even
the information about Dan Quayle and and
Mike Pence which I'll get to in a second
about the desperation of Pence to to
please Grandpa Poopypants that the
orange deity mango Mussolini Jesus
to get on his his knees put his Cheeto
dust knee pads on and please him
he was looking for justification
justification from Dan Quayle but this
select committee that we have
is unpacking this piece by piece by
piece by piece and that's the design
the design is to make sure that the
American people
can eat the elephant because this is an
elephant and you don't eat an elephant
in one goddamn bite you don't eat it
with a straw you gotta cut that
[__] up in little pieces and eat
it with a spoon or a fork
and that's what the select committee is
designed to do now they originally
wanted a 911 committee
that way it could be unpacked that way
but yeah you couldn't do that couldn't
do that because Republicans didn't want
this information out
because now we see with the select
committee why they didn't want it out
and want it out because they were part
of this they were part of the Cheeto
dust kangaroo coup
that's why they're all pissed off about
Mark milley for stopping a coup
it got stopped on January 6 and mark
milley for
better worse his duty his not duty but
his oath
made him make sure he did the right
thing
and keep our constitution intact
make sure the Constitution lived not
died
because Donald Trump was willing and is
still willing to wipe his ass with it
and so is all the gqp for that matter
they don't give a [__] about the
Constitution frankly the Constitution is
their enemy and the reason why it's
their enemy is because it gives us
democracy
it gives us freedom and rights which
delivers us to Liberty
and when you're a fascist you're a
fascist the Citizen's Liberty is not
what you want
it's not a thing you really want you
don't want them to have Liberty
you don't want them to have autonomy you
know especially women
or anybody that doesn't look like them
you know white male
but if you really gqp if you really want
a traitor a general that's a traitor
if you really want a traitor who betray
our country and you're looking for a
treason a trial of treason maybe you
should look no further than a queue
the Q Anon General Michael Flynn this
guy has taken O's to q and on the Q Anon
oath he doesn't pledge allegiance to the
flag he pledge allegiance to cue the Q
Anon
this guy's running around the country
talking about having a civil war
and and and committing a coup and having
the military take over that's what he's
that's what they've been saying for
months and months and months is all the
military should take over the military
should do something and here we are here
we are with the story that Mark milley
The Joint chief of staff
he's like oh I got to make sure that
everyone knows the protocols
for war so that this [__] bonehead
doesn't [__] his diaper and commit a war
and just because he wants to stay in
power for no other reason
and ever since that day they've been
saying the military the military I mean
remember March 4th
now this this bleeds into a lot of
different conspiracy theories
this bleeds into it they're really they
they overlap these this this narrative
and maritime law and Sovereign citizen
[__] that's how they got to this this
March 4th thing because they got to it
because oh well it was in the old
Constitution before they Incorporated
the country and it became a company and
and they changed the inauguration date
so he was the military was going to take
back control of the country and dissolve
the corporation or I don't know what the
[__]
what the [__] they were did it has
something to do with Sovereign citizen
citizenry these people who claim to be
Sovereign citizens there's a few of
these goddamn insurrections that are
trying to uh defend themselves in court
as Sovereign citizens go Google it
Sovereign citizen it's [__] dumb it's
[__] dumb they think maritime law and
all kinds of dumb [__] but that's why
they thought he was going to take over
March 4th but you remember
the whole [__] point was oh well
we're going to here's what we're gonna
do we're gonna have the military exit
Joe Biden and swear in Donald Trump as
the 19th president they've been calling
for the military to take over this
country
since Donald Trump [__] lost
are you people not paying attention
Linwood Cindy Powell Mike Flynn Mike
Lindell they've all been saying the
military needs to do something the
military the military the military and
then they're like what Mark milley the
military they did what
trailers to reason
because they were stopping Grandpa poopy
pants from [__] the bed for the last
two weeks he was a president after
January 6 happened after it was obvious
what he wanted he wanted to remain the
American dictator it was obvious
we seen it live on TV
and we've seen the lead up to it he kept
he kept leading up to it with the big
lie I mean Jesus Christ Bill Bill Barr
was even like nope that [__] scumbag
was like no I'm not gonna have anything
to do with it he resigns
he knew it was coming
and really if we're gonna have someone
tried for treason maybe try Bill Barr
who didn't say anything who didn't say
hey hey he's gonna try to commit a coup
it's gonna be a coup attempt
hello
he's gonna try to commit a coup because
you know if Mark milley called
his counterpart counterpart in China
at that [__] buffoon was in the White
House talking about how he could start a
nuclear war and that would keep him as
president you know it you know it's true
how could it not be true
why the [__] would Mark milley ever
assume
that Donald Trump was used nuclear
weapons if it didn't come out of his
mouth and it ain't that far-fetched
it really isn't that far-fetched I mean
this is
you're not too many steps away from this
I mean he was going to Nuke a hurricane
you remember that [__]
make it nuclear
but also in this book we find out to add
to to add to the problems
of these [__] morons
trying to
set the narrative that oh it was a coup
attempt against Trump
is Mike Pence
wasn't the innocent little puppy on
January 6th
the [__] was calling Dan Quayle
to try to get justification in public I
think that was the attempt
Mike Pence is trying to find someone and
I bet he was goated by Grandpa
Poopypants the Cheeto dust mobster this
is what they do with the big lie and
misinformation that was the whole point
of Ukraine is to get someone to come out
in public in a microphone and then they
could say see people are saying people
are saying people are saying
that's what they that's what they're
trying to do with Dan quill goading
Pence and to go go asking quail
to give him justification for
overturning the election on January 6th
and of course Dan Dan quell dropped a
[__] load of Truth on Pence's dumb
ass
that you do not have that power that is
not that's not a thing that [__]
exists you need to stop acting like it
exists don't even talk about it you're
acting like it exists just by talking
about it with me
you [__] bonehead
but Mike Pence apparently calls Dan
Quayle now the significance of Dan
Quayle here I believe
is that
um Mike Pence is looking for
justification not just from a republican
from the state of Indiana but he's also
looking for justification for someone
who is in the same situation and you
look back in history and he's one of the
most recent cases of this where an
incumbent president loses their race
and the vice president of the United
States who loses the incumbency race
has to hand over power they have to have
the peaceful transfer of power in the
joint session of Congress
way of counting the state's vote to
certify the state's vote
and really it's all ceremonial it's like
opening up an envelope and saying who
won at the Oscars they already won the
[__] Oscar they already won it it's
just a matter of saying it out loud and
they come up and oh yay here here's your
here's your trophy I mean that's all it
is it's just a [__] Trophy ceremony
that's it it's already done it's already
certified it's already legal the states
have already decided there was no
different electors there was one slate
and the Slate of electors had elected
Joe Biden that was it
but Mike Pence was looking for
justification here not just from a
republican but also from a republican
who was in the same situation as he was
sorta
because Joe Biden was the vice president
he handed over power to Donald Trump and
Mike Pence
but they weren't incumbents they
couldn't win
Al Gore the same way now Al Gore is a
little different situation because Al
Gore had to hand over power
to George W bush and Dick Cheney after a
long fought battle in the Supreme Court
and he had to hand over power to them
but he he wasn't incumbent he wasn't the
incumbent he was the vice president but
he was running to be president
the last time we seen this where the
incumbent lost and the vice president
had to give the transfer of power inside
the joint session of Congress to certify
the state's vote was Dan Quayle
and that's why Mike Pence called Dan
Quayle
that's why
because I know I know from history
of listening to the Trump Administration
and Trump and Pence and anyone else tied
to [__] trumpism here that they were
looking for someone to go out in public
and say yes he can do it yes and they
were looking for someone who would quote
unquote No
that he could do it give them
justification
sanity that this isn't the story
that the guy who can't spell potato is
the guy they were looking for to give
public justification for something that
didn't exist and Mike Pence pressed him
on it you see it in the quotes he
pressed in me are you sure nah I'm sure
positive not a thing that exists are you
double time sure
100 there's not a chance in the world
what about in an alternative Universe
would there be a chance would there be a
chance nope sorry Mike not a thing can't
do it you gotta abide by the
Constitution it's your [__] duty
so in essence Dan Quayle and Mark milley
might have saved our [__] democracy
they might have saved our democracy
now I believe there's probably a lot of
other people out there that had to do
with saving our democracy than just mark
milley and Dan Quayle
but it's really [__] it's really [__]
crazy
that we were so close
because I don't believe we were really
close but we were closer than we've ever
been
to losing our Constitution of the United
States and the thing that stood in the
way was Mark milley
and a guy who couldn't spell potato
holy [__]
how fragile is democracy
how fragile is it
it's really [__] fragile folks that's
why
that's why the call to go vote vote vote
vote vote
that should be the call right now the
next election the next the next proof
that we need that we will reject
trumpism in this country
is the Virginia gubaterial race it's
where we need to go
that's where our Focus Needs To Go
California behind us
we'd unpile the mountain of [__]
a mountain of votes
on trumpism [__] that [__] we don't want
it let's go to a different state and
prove there that we don't want it there
and let's keep doing this
let's keep piling these elections on top
of these dumb [__]
We're Not Gonna Get rid of fascism
fascism is an idea
and trumpism is fascism with a Maga hat
on
can't kill an idea
but what we can do is make sure it
doesn't have [__] power and the
Reigns of power now it's going to be
very difficult
with the redistrict redistricting that's
going to happen with the United States
census that they that they [__]
rigged up
it's gonna be really [__] difficult
but we can [__] do it
we can do it over and over and over and
over again
there's eight million plus
more voters that are for democracy and
against fascism with a goddamn Maga head
on trumpism
we need to keep piling votes on these
[__] Texas Florida
Arizona Georgia Virginia is the next one
could actually have more implications
of fascism taking over our country
than what the 2020 race had
so just remember that
you have a duty too to your rights and
your freedom to deliver you Liberty
because that's what it is our rights and
our freedom Deliver Us Liberty
and if you want Liberty you better go
vote you better go vote and you better
go vote for someone who is for rights
and freedoms because the freedom to
oppress the rights of other people Texas
Greg Abbott DeSantis
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty it's not
it's not [__] Liberty
and until we get to a place in this
country
where everyone that's here I don't care
if you're man woman black white tall
short
able-bodied disabled
if you're a citizen or a non-citizen
you are entitled to Liberty any equality
and Equity of that Liberty and that
doesn't mean that doesn't mean that your
privilege is taken away for you from you
you fragile white males
just because someone gets equality in
the privilege that you've had for
hundreds of years doesn't mean you're
losing anything you stupid bastards
pluck your head out of your ass and
realize and tell all of us
every single person in this country
has full Liberty autonomy of our bodies
the rights and freedoms that are
afforded to us in the Constitution
without restriction from the state that
you live in
until that happens until that happens no
one has full Liberty nobody and that's
the way they want it
that's what fascism does
that's what it's designed to do and our
fascism in this country wears a [__]
Moga hat
it's [__] trumpism so go vote
vote vote vote vote
and remember it only takes two words
[__] them you've been listening to the
Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[__] them [__] em